you know i i trust my enemies a lot i
trust them a lot because i know my
enemies have a very uh honest outcome
right they want to eliminate you it's
very they want to eliminate you and they
want to beat you it's that so you have
to trust your enemies right in that
context yes what makes sense okay so if
if we trust uh our enemies and
we look at today what's going on in the
world who doesn't like america you may
have to put iran china and russia in
that group you know as of right now
those are the three countries this is
very you know fluid it changes sometimes
but as of right now those are the three
okay what what is from your experience
what's china's
russia's and iran's i'm talking ji i'm
not talking to people of china i'm
talking yes putin i'm talking at the top
what is their fear
and
a paranoia
and handling of climate change how are
they strategizing to fight against
climate change are they putting any time
into it are they putting any resources
into it what are they doing okay i've
extensively studied russia and china a
little less clear on iran iran i don't
think you know cares that much about it
but they're the beneficiary we can start
with iran
is the beneficiary of climate policy so
the more the west commits itself to
green new deal to net zero to build back
better we're going to be more reliant on
rogue regimes if you will like iran and
also like venezuela in terms of the way
russia and china china and russia are
the biggest beneficiaries of this entire
climate agenda at the moment it's
incredible
russian the when uh price of gas
barrel goes above oil goes above 40
russia then starts getting uh funding
and it's a huge exponential increase
when it's below 40 a barrel
russia doesn't get extra money in their
coffers so what's happened is with our
shutting down europe and the united
states and canada of our domestic energy
remember europe is way ahead of us
they literally started shutting down
their fracking they shut down their coal
price of electricity has been
skyrocketing across europe you have a
few bright spots in places like france
where they allow nuclear and support
nuclear but
essentially what they've done and you
had uk prime minister uh
what's boris johnson i always want to
say tony blair boris johnson in 2019
pouring concrete into fracking wells in
the uk as a virtue signal to how they
were going to be committed to net zero
climate goals
50 years of natural gas from these wells
poured cement over
now what happened during the 10 years
radical increase in reliance on russian
energy and that included germany or some
some country i think germany is 40 near
50
all of europe is like 38 39 near 40
their reliance on vladimir putin's
russia why is russia able to do all this
because they're not following the
dictates of the united nations of they
don't have a domestic green new deal you
don't see putin putin will pay lip
service as needed
but it has been the greatest boon to
russian uh aggression russian national
interest
china
same it basically the same
premise
china loves the premise of
the the once free democratic west
shutting themselves down energy wise and
doing what making us more reliant on
china 90 of our solar panels come from
there 90 of rare earth mining china has
cobalt mines in africa that amnesty
international 60 they own yeah kids as
young as nine allegedly doing slave
labor in china and then at the same time
you'll get your starbucks mom or someone
in america who's like oh i you know we
have to buy only things that are
certified and ethical but at the same
time they're shutting down our domestic
fossil fuels which are the cleanest
greatest standards in the world because
of everything we've done
since the first earth day and i talked
in my powerpoint
i you to your point i think it was a
very important thing you said today
because rush limbaugh was an entertainer
and rush limbaugh
you know had a core audit but i and i do
come from that world where you know
essentially four years of this tv show
and i love rush limbaugh but i'm trying
now especially in this post-covet age
especially in the censorship age where
we got to win people over and i'm very
excited when i see people like naomi
wolf and robert f kennedy and jimmy dore
and russell brand who by the way russell
brandt is my new favorite number one
favorite political commentator probably
followed by jimmy dore
yeah he is but never even heard of the
guy pre-covet i mean i heard of him as
an actor but not as i remember him as a
socialist or something being on fox news
and they're making anyway
i was sort of losing my train of thought
on that one uh you said you agree with
the point i made at the beginning that
oh yeah that i'm actually trying now
especially in the last two years since
rush limbaugh yeah to to be less
divisive and to actually i have a whole
chapter in my upcoming book
including all the progressives who agree
with us on tyranny i now believe it's no
longer a left-right political battle and
that went on for way too long it's now
basically tyranny versus freedom and we
welcome anyone on our side with that so
when i give presentations you know i'll
praise the first earth days because the
first earth they had a lot of wacky
elements a lot of ridiculous predictions
and
but
it essentially laid out a very big
concern about filthy rivers filthy air
and just major environmental problems
that we had well we got the message and
it wasn't because of government
regulation it was because we made
ourselves aware and we had radical
improvements in human air quality human
water quality while at the same time
huge population increases and huge
economic growth we did it leading the
world essentially and so how it can be
done through innovation technology and
the more wealth you have the cleaner the
environment you have but back to china
my only thought final thing there is
china loves the climate agenda it makes
it we're going to get off american
energy independence and dominance which
beginning at covid 2020 we were the
world's largest oil and gas producer we
were we had more energy production than
consumption more energy exports than
imports for the first time since harry s
truman was president
and that'll of course topple with covid
and then with biden coming in and you
know even further decimating fossil
fuels and that wasn't just executive
orders it was the defunding of it so
china is sitting pretty russia's sitting
pretty
and they'll always say climate change
causes more war no when you shut down
your domestic energy and you rely on
hostile regimes that's what causes more
conflict when now instead of relying on
american and canadian oil and europe
relying on their own oil and then
killing a pipeline for the east med
pipeline from israel to poland and
eastern europe
they've been relying on russia they'll
be increasingly relying on china and
then of course the perverseness is they
do sanctions on putin we're going to
stick it to putin and that when you pay
more for gas you're sticking it to putin
all it's done is hurt american consumers
while putin sells his uh energy to
talking
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]